what is happening there reject nation
greg here today so um case you guys
didn't get the memo john tested positive
for the vid diesel
on monday and then on wednesday i tested
positive as well fortunately after all
this time i just checked it's the
weekend now coy
negative i'm totally fine you know
lucky duck in this time of quarantining
here i i've been watching more comedies
and that's been making me feel a lot
better and so i was like what comedies
have i not seen i'm not that well versed
in mel brooks's comedies actually
and i realized i've never seen the movie
blazing saddles i saw like a handful of
requests for it not a ton but i was like
you know what it's been on my mind ever
since i've been hearing those requests
i've been covering more classic films
lately so i figured why don't i try a
classic comedy while i'm at it but guys
thank you so much for being here if you
can subscribe to the real rejects click
that notification bell to get notified
when a reaction of ours that you you're
like yeah it looks good and i wanted to
check that out um yeah that's the whole
point of doing it and you know leave a
like that'd be very much appreciated too
please leave a like full length reaction
watch alongs where you sync up with your
own copy or over at our patreon for
super sexy rejects cover a bunch of
stuff over there where at the same tier
you get the option for reaction
highlights and watch along the included
team of prepper i know you guys
especially right now are helping me edit
this down so thank you guys you know i
figured why not i'm feeling all right
right now feeling all right so i figured
yeah let's uh
let's sit back relax and enjoy comedy
together
[Music]
it's really weird to go from catching up
on westworld to watching this that's
probably why i'm in the mood to watch it
actually
where's your spirit i don't hear no
singing
when you were slaves you sang like birds
come on how about a good old [ __ ] work
song oh my god i
get no kick
from champagne
oh they're really doing this that i
get
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
the camptown lady sing this song
[Music]
oh my god
[Laughter]
the surveyors say they may run into some
quicksand up ahead better check it out
sent over a couple of these
okay mr tiger
sir he uh specifically requested two
[ __ ]
my grandmother was a dutch
i knew your grandma was dutch
oh
the camptown ladies sing
dude
[Music]
ah dang now we are in trouble
they in trouble
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
we can't swing back to the right because
that hill there that looks like we will
have to go
yeah yeah we'll put her right down
through over that ring oh wow they're
doing it ah baby
don't do that i have to send the wire to
the main office do it bart and tell him
what i said ow
yes when that railroad goes through rock
ridge that land will be worth millions
and i want it
i want that land oh my god land
snatching
let's see land let land
see snatch
[Laughter]
i know how we can run everybody out of
rock ridge how we'll kill the first born
male child in every household
jesus
too jewish
[Laughter]
i've got a special when can you work him
in i couldn't possibly sneak him in
until monday
[Music]
they have a special kind of bond
[Music]
good sunset
oh wow
oh jeez
[Music]
[Laughter]
now the time has come to act
and act fast
i'm leaving
hell i was born here and i was raised
here and they're coming i'm gonna die
here and an old say raining bushwhacking
is gonna roll away
well said now who can argue with that
[Laughter]
i think we're all indebted to gabby
johnson
for clearly stating what
[Laughter]
olson johnson is right i say we stay and
fight it out dr samuel johnson's right
about olson johnson's being right
my ice cream car that i built with these
two hands for nothing or nobody howard
johnson is right right
we're gonna need us a new sheriff now
who's it gonna be why don't we wire the
governor to send us a share why should
we get our own men kill
howard johnson is right
i shall now read from the books of
matthew
mark
luke
and duck
nice
governor the governor may i disturb you
for a moment sir
i know that's mel brooks
thank you thank you hedy thank you it's
not hedy it's headley headley lamar what
the hell are you worried about
all right help me in with this help me
in with this help me instead think of
your secretary uh yeah that was a very
good suggestion all right thank you all
right okay is that it just think of your
secretary we've got to protect our phony
baloney jobs gentlemen we must do
something about this
is adjourned
oh i am sorry sir i didn't mean to
overstep my bounds you say that what
meeting is adjourned it is no you say
that
taking a look around what can i do for
you governor as per your instructions
i'd like you to meet the new sheriff
i'd be delighted wow
i've got to talk to you come here have
you gone for circuit you see that that
man is a nick
wrong person forgive me no offense
lieutenant
have you gone for sir
it'll never work they'll kill him dead
in one day one day is all we'll need to
secure your name in the annals of
western history and to get for you a
nomination for did i say there there the
presidency
i could see it happening maybe not back
then but now are you coming back in a
moment dear uh gentlemen gentlemen
affairs of state must take precedent
over uh the affairs of state
[Music]
not a bad look man
as honorary chairman of the welcoming
committee it is my privilege to extend
to you a laurel and hearty handshake
wonderful
very well done sir
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you got this man
be cool
oh he's cool it is my privilege to
extend the laurel and hearty handshake
to our new
oh my god
[Music]
[Laughter]
he's great
excuse me while i whip this out
[Laughter]
gentlemen let us not allow i'm good to
rule the day
as your spiritual leader i implore you
to play heed to this good book and what
it has to say
hold it
the next man makes a move and never gets
it
loaded on he's desperate do what he says
somebody help me hit me help me
hit me shut up
oh
baby you are so talented
to the honorable william j lepedaman
governor
[Applause]
wish to express our extreme displeasure
with your choice of sheriff you are the
leading [ __ ] in the state
send the cows in
drunk and number two must be awake
are we awake are we
black yes we are then we're awake but
we're very puzzled
[Laughter]
well my name is tim since you are my
guest and i am your host what you like
to do well i don't know
play chess
screw
let's play chess
it's a really good cut
i don't know if you ever heard of me
before but i used to be called the waco
kid he had the fastest hands in the west
no [ __ ] well if you're the kid then show
me something well maybe a couple of
years ago i could have shown you
something but
today look at that
steady as a rock
yeah but i shoot with this hand
[Laughter]
and when i say go
you try to grab it first go
wow magic david blaine
you're looking for this
you are the kid was
yeah i was the kid
i mean you still got it man if you could
do that [ __ ] i was just
walking down the street and i heard a
voice behind me say reach for it mister
i spun around and there i was face to
face with a six-year-old kid
well i just threw my guns down walked
away little bastard shot me in the ass
[Laughter]
i limped to the nearest saloon
crawl inside a whiskey bottle
and
i've been there ever since
have a drink
thanks
man dream wilder was something huh it's
being sound good right now
beans don't sound good anymore
[Music]
this must be what it's really like
[Music]
i understand there's a new sheriff in
town who wants to kill me
[Applause]
why don't we give him to [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
that shot aston
martin
did i just get way ahead of myself
listen bart
[Laughter]
i don't want you going out there this
morning you can't win these people over
no matter what you do they're just not
gonna accept you
i'm glad those uh fingers ain't loaded
once you establish yourself they got to
accept you catch you later
good luck
[Laughter]
good morning ma'am
and isn't it a lovely morning
up yours
oh my god
did you expect it's just that one person
these are people of the land the common
clay of the new west you know
morons
kind of played like an outtake it's
played so sincere
candy gram for mango
sign please
manga-like candy
did it work kyle darn it mr lamar
you use your tongue prettier than a 20
[ __ ]
[ __ ] kicker
wait a minute [ __ ] kicker where's my
froggy oh i didn't see it want to come
in well look damn your eyes look for it
i'm good
sorry sir
you look around where are you how many
things give it to me hurry
quick jacket quick
that was a close one
daddy loves froggy
froggy love daddy
good evening sheriff
sorry about the up yours
pile in some small way say thank you for
your ingenuity and courage in defeating
that horrible mongol thank you very much
good night of course you'll have the
good taste not to mention that i spoke
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh no the seductress for you my dear how
old nelly
lilly
lilly legs lily really
i cannot find the words to truly express
my joy
so creepy [ __ ]
what's the job i love it when you talk
dirty
i want you to seduce and abandon the
sheriff of rock ridge
do you think you can do it it's bismarck
a helling oh lily you're magnificent
kiss me
oh god ouch
let's sear it for lily vaughn
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i've been with thousands
of men they're always coming and going
and going and coming
oh i just got it
[Applause]
[Music]
i really like this song
for you
oh
a wet rose
how romantic
[Laughter]
why don't you uh
loosen your bullets
nice
ah
wow how's it going tastes like wet
sauerkraut in my hands
by morning he would be my slave splendid
you just let me have a little fear
is it uh true what they say about the
way you people are
gifted
oh it's two
it's two
it's two it's two
would you care for another schnitzel but
[Laughter]
i'll be the same baby
oh what a nice guy
[Music]
wake up time
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh you better watch out big fella
i think mango is taking a little fancy
to you
oh god why would hedley lamarr care
about where the choo choo go
no no [ __ ] only pawn
in game of life
i think this might be a good time to
mosey out where they're building on the
railroad and maybe do a little snooping
yes but
choo choo
i sure do hate to see you like this what
if me and the
boys that you're dead would that pick
you up some that might heal
all right boys on a count of three i
wouldn't do that if i were you oh
fastest gun in the west the world he
can't even hold a gun much less shoot it
[Music]
[Laughter]
i want you to round up every vicious
criminal and gunslinger in the west take
this down i want rustlers
cutthroats murderers bounty hunters
desperados mugs pugs thugs nitwits
halfwits dimwits
this can't get
just give me 24 hours to come up with a
brilliant idea to save our town
just 24 hours that's all i ask
you do it for randolph scott
[Music]
you know they really don't make spoof
movies like this
anymore
wow these are really all kinds of people
there's our ticket
hey boys
look what i got here
hey where are the white women at
and now for my next impression
jesse owens
seize them
[Music]
this guy's always got a smile on his
face i really like it they bring the
production design to life on this and
they tell an actual western
story lamar and his men come riding in
to destroy the real rock ridge they'll
actually be destroying the fake rock
ridge how are we gonna do it we ain't
got the time and we ain't got the people
wrong there's why who the hell are they
this is like
defeating races do we have the strength
to carry on this mighty task in one
night or are we just jerking off
[Music]
they did it
[Music]
[Applause]
men
you are about to embark on a great
crusade
to stamp up now you will only be risking
your lives
whilst i
will be risking an almost certain
academy award nomination
for best supporting actor
i got an idea that'll slow him down to a
crawl all right let's go all right come
on
the pedometer way
now one ladder [ __ ] think of next
[Laughter]
somebody's got to go back and get a
shitload of dimes
[Music]
no that's like 300
back then well they're through the tone
booth
[Music]
hold your ears folks it's show time
come on
[Music]
oh lord keep this man's eye keen and my
god
no
oh cool
[Music]
wow
i'm so
there's so many horses falling over it
gets me so nervous
[Laughter]
it was a movie we were watching the
whole time give me the playback and
watch me
[Laughter]
how do you got it yeah
what's going on
[Music]
[Applause]
what a finale
thank you
buddy come on girls
[Applause]
i'm parked over by the commissary
[Laughter]
it's really all done
well how many days you have left joey
they lose me right after the bunker
scene
[Laughter]
where some hollywood stars come to eat
keep in mind
yeah it'll hurt the backer
[Music]
oh
[Music]
really looks like they did not stop
traffic at all for this shot
this is so so breaking the fourth wall
before there was deadpool there was
blazing saddles
student are you kidding
ain't in the ass
look herman i'm in hedy lamarr's shoes
[Laughter]
wow just at the man's chinese theater a
couple weeks ago
[Music]
oh
worst spot
how did he do such fantastic stunts
such little feat
wow you shot the bad guy well what do
you want to do now headley lamar sheriff
you can't go now we need you
work here is done
this is so crazy good luck bart and god
bless you
oh
[Laughter]
[Applause]
in the end he was respected by the town
where are you headed cowboy nowhere
special
like how he still has the popcorn i
always wanted to go there
come on
leave this town to fend for themselves
[Music]
do not expect this movie to become that
hyper self-aware
i had to see if i read that right
richard pryor was one of the writers on
this that is kind of crazy a lot of
people wrote on this
well well okay um
i didn't know anything about blazing
saddles before going into this film i
really didn't so
to
to be here with this film i you know i
just sort of expected
walking into a
spoof comedy about the west that's just
all i kind of ever heard about it i
remember when the movie seth
macfarlane's a million ways to die in
the west came out
that's when i heard a lot of people
going like no blazing saddles though
it's no blazing that's all i ever heard
so i just only assumed that about this
film and
i i didn't i feel like you got to talk
about the comedy and then also whoa
there's a lot of uh other additional
commentary here that i
did not expect to be walking into with
this film uh i i didn't realize just how
non-politically correct it is you know
if you if you don't
don't don't never talk to me about mel
brooks because i don't know anything
about mel brooks other than i'm familiar
with like oh yeah he said young
frankenstein it's baseballs uh the
producers i'm actually not familiar with
those movies though other than the
association of mel book mel brooks tied
with those so yeah
it's like this uh
i was so surprised to be watching a film
that was
so much more than just some funny movie
from the 70s like i could i was trying i
found myself kind of going in and out
uh thinking how was this received at the
at the time it came out because it was
like in the 70s at some point that this
film
was released
and
and it's so much a satire about racism
and i had no clue that that's what i was
walking into here because at times i was
going was were these jokes here just for
shock value or did they serve an actual
purpose and
as i was you know just settling into the
movie because i i think it was around
the time when he arrived into town uh
bart where the town realized like oh my
god we got a black sheriff here
that's when the movie started to
really start clicking for me
and
it started becoming a real movie
more than just a series of sketch
comedies kind of like slapped together
into one it started becoming a real
movie for me around the time when gene
wilder was introduced the relationship
with bart and jim started to develop
and it was even interesting seeing how
that was uh portrayed because you know
the the interracial buddy comedy thing
has has been a thing around for for a
long time and i gotta imagine that this
was one of the first movies
uh or i don't know if it was the first
movie but one of the earlier ones
to do it but i i really liked with that
relationship
how
it it it never became the cliche of
clash of white men and black man and and
their cultures like they just had a an
understanding for who they were as
individuals and respected it never
became about race with them you know
other than when jim was at the initial
offset when he meets jim and is like
surprised to see a black man as the
sheriff he's there's nothing really more
beyond that never became about them
butting heads or jokes about the
difference in how they perceive things
or or [ __ ] like that which is usually
one of the go-to things you do with
interracial buddy comedies right
and i like that they didn't do that they
just uh they blew right past that and it
became a mutual respect for each other
right away and there's a natural
friendship so i think even from like the
interracial buddy comedy standpoint i
really like the execution of it and with
this one
uh back to the the actual comedy of the
the racist
satire
it it was interesting how it was used
because they were obviously taking some
one like it seems like they're taking
jokes
at uh racism
and
of course hollywood and some of those
jokes uh kind of weirdly the hollywood
jokes are the ones that are kind of
flying over my head like i believe the
the
the headly heady joke is there's an
actual uh actress right uh hedy lamarr
uh am i correct about that at least
that's what i thought they were making
fun of i could be wrong i might just be
remembering something completely
incorrect but that's what it sounded
like they were making fun of and then
obviously they really break the fourth
wall but
what i thought was cool about the kind
of world that this is playing in is
they're using the classic hollywood at
least with the the writing in what mel
brooks directed here is they're using
the classic hollywood background
of a classic hollywood westerns
and
it feels and looks like a classic
hollywood western
and you can kind of compare it to today
with uh with how you know sketch spoof
movies really start to go down in
quality like they're so much fewer or
far between but there was a time where
we get a lot of spoof comedies and and
uh they just started looking like cheap
sketches after a while and i thought
that this still looks like a classic
hollywood western film so it has like
the sheen of that but it's also
showing
the the ugliness i would say
it's sort of of the
the foundation
in which america
was built like the the actual ugliness
and kind of forcing you to look at it
so that's why i actually thought some of
the straightforwardness of especially
with some of the the comedy like with
the use of the n-word for example
was
yeah at first like kind of shocking to
hear
but it started i started to click with
me then i don't feel like it's actually
being used for shock it's actually sort
of being
used as not just the use of that word
but the treatment and then you know
seeing the people who built the
railroads and because they start taking
jabs at every single stereotype at some
point in this film like every stereotype
starts to get a bit of a jab at it like
they're pulling back a veil and showing
sort of the the
looking for the right words here the
ugliness
of
of the like american history
and
at the time in which this move is made
and the fact that it still [ __ ]
exists today so weirdly this actually
has a bit of a timeless quality to it
even though it's a 70s movie uh
you know 70s comedy movie
but i i thought that using like i said
the sheen of classic westerns
but
with
some of the ruthlessness like they kind
of seem contrasting with each other
so it really forces you to kind of look
at it and examine it so i like that
there's a bit of this intellectual
comedy side to it that's a little more
elevated than i actually expected it to
be like you really i don't know how you
can make
this movie today
and i i was finding myself even thinking
about that because it's so
non-pc it's just so non-pc and it's also
anti-hollywood at the same time so to be
doing both of those in one film
i i would find it very hard for people
because something like this you know i
think can be really
misinterpreted the wrong way and i feel
like i'm interpreting it the way it's
intended to be at least that's the i
feel like this is the way to interpret
it and that's how at least reads to me
because i think nowadays a lot of times
people might try to try something like
this now
it could just be reading as a movie
that's like trying to be anti-woke and
go against cancel culture and do this
kind of comedy and it feels forced and i
feel like arguably they might make it
feel forced we're here and putting
myself trying or like i'm born in 1990s
so i don't know what it's like to live
in that time i only have an awareness of
what i've ever learned from history
lessons or movies or whatever of what
the time was like back then and i i can
only imagine just how much more of a
of a of a social commentary spoof movie
and a more effective this this actually
was for back then and then you got to
think about the stepper side like how is
it just as a comedy movie in in total
there is where
uh and maybe what like it's weird i had
one one thing with this movie that i was
so surprised by and that i respected
admire about it so much of like being
willing to tackle that and at times had
some just truly laugh out loud jokes at
times is truly hilarious uh overall i
thought it was funny
i was i didn't think it was um this
hilarious romp that i've always heard
about that it's just like just one of
the best comedies of all time i and i
see how why it would be such a valuable
comedy and an important one for
um american history
but right now for me this time maybe
it's because i'm not feeling the
greatest or whatever but even if i think
if i was still feeling 100 i might i'd
probably still walk away thinking the
same thing which is that yeah it's had
some really funny moments
but
i guess at times it felt too much
like
even though i was admiring the the way
it was made and filmed and that's what i
mean by how it stopped it does it
surpasses what a lot of spoof movies do
now which is they feel like sketches
and here this didn't
feel like a sketch but yet it still kind
of kept playing
like a series of sketches after after a
certain time and
i feel like some of those best spoof
movies nowadays and granted this is an
earlier time and it's a very specific
style
i feel like the the kind of thing i
crave a little bit more of is to
actually feel just a little bit more of
that actual character an actual heart
uh throughout the film instead of just
jokes
you know and i think that's why gene
wilder's uh by jim and
and bart are so effective together in
their scenes because that's when you
start to get like real
moments with more unexpected comedy
lines that come out of gene wilder or
bart in those scenes when they they feel
like this is a real just a real movie
when it when it's with them and has some
great comedy and some wackiness
and some really heightened bits that are
unrealistic and stuff but it still
manages to maintain
uh like a good sense of soul at that
point and then here
throughout and then i don't know what
i'm saying here but throughout the rest
of the movie
it um
it did feel like really well-made comedy
bits albeit
it wasn't like oh it was kind of funny
and then i just stopped laughing
throughout
i would find myself at least like every
other scene having a good laugh at at
least something in there and i do
appreciate the fact that they brought
like so many classic western cliches and
tropes into here because it also seemed
to have
as much as it was taking a dig at you
know the the the the
the truth
uh this ugly truth
within the american foundation
it it also simultaneously seemed to have
a love
for those westerns it didn't
seem like there was criticizing the
western movies necessarily it seemed
like they were actually
kind of uh honoring it in in some way
you could feel there's some level of
reverence
on top of
exposing like
within its deconstruction
so it didn't seem like it was just an
insult towards that and i it do you guys
kind of get what i'm getting at with
this i feel like i i'm making sense at
least in my own i think it makes sense
that yeah it's doing a lot and i
appreciated that it was more than just
a straightforward comedy because it was
just a straightforward comedy about you
know just like do these jokes still land
do these jokes still work after all
these years
then i would walk away going every once
in a while yeah
but because it's actually got more going
on underneath the surface
it made me appreciate it a lot more than
i expected to in that regard so as a as
a comedy movie i go yeah it's still
funny
i want to say it's like hilarious a
couple of hilarious moments still funny
um
did i expect to kind of laugh more and
consistently and throughout yeah i mean
you're watching reaction highlights then
you know
mainly just the parts i i found funny so
it looks like i'm just cracking up that
but uh in terms of like you know when if
you did the watch along you would know
that oh yeah not every there's there's a
lot of jokes that are just kind of like
but uh in terms of being surprised by
how there's more nuance to the film and
and a cool social commentary that i
think is even applicable to today
movie has my respect movie has my
respect
so yeah that was a that was a surprise
and forgive me as i'm still learning how
to talk i go three days without talking
on camera and i'm like
how do i be again and i'm still
under the weather right now so
appreciate you guys being here and i'm
glad i watched it because i was just
going to watch it in a bed but um
because i got this place and then
there's a back room that i'm staying at
so just
between these two two sections all the
time
and uh yeah i was just gonna watch it
over there but i started watching with
you guys classic
hollywood film
and i don't know if i've seen any other
mel brooks movies
i i feel like i've seen some of
spaceballs to say the least
um
but in terms of what is mel brooks
comedy style i have no idea this this to
me feels like a pure introduction to it
but it sounds like he's established his
name after a certain point
because of uh
the
fact that there was like meta jokes
about it being mel brooks in the end
anywho thank you guys for being here but
before we go i'd like to end this with a
patron of the day shout out
maria hammond maria
i just wanted to say to you
that i love you
and there were some people being total
[ __ ] to you in discord
and they can go [ __ ] themselves i'm
sorry you had to deal with that
uh that was a bunch of [ __ ]
and
i want you to know
that
they don't matter to me you matter you
matter a lot you've been an amazing
beautiful soul to me
uh in more ways than one and you you
reach out to me on very genuine tender
levels and that
i constantly find very touching and i'm
incredibly appreciative of you you mean
the absolute world to me
and you're one of the best souls i've
ever known you got an insanely gracious
heart
and
it pains me to see people
be such [ __ ] to you like that
because you don't deserve that
and
you're better than them in every way
you're the [ __ ]
you're the you're you're the all you're
[ __ ] i don't know i i just realized
people say you're the [ __ ] and then i'm
like sort of thinking about
you [ __ ] it's kind of a weird thing if
you're like you just put there another
word in there it's not very insulting
you know you're you're the [ __ ] sounds
cool you're a piece of [ __ ] sounds just
[ __ ] awful but no you're
you're you're the bum and
just know that
whatever mean things they were saying
that's not at all how
i perceive you whatsoever
you're
you're very near and dear to my heart
and remember that please
please remember that
i love you
[Music]
you